un jour on compte cinq mrc du gabon
aximum bien un jour là j'ai genre je
vous jure je sais bien
[Musique]
vous voulez laquelle elle est à 15 euros
merci 20 carottes 40,50 sentiments pour
les barbecues pas non merci
c'est pour moi et ça c'est pour
le temps après c'était quand j'étais
petit j'allais rencontre un sans abri
qui nous saisit a bouleversé mon destin
du coup j'ai voulu les
[Musique]
des choses particulières vous voyez bien
que ce n'était pas satisfaisant de juste
donner une pièce est parti hier et qu'il
avait besoin de créer ce contact il me
dit mais arthur plutôt que de donner
cette pièce il peut être satisfait
réfléchir c'est vraiment comme ça que ça
s'est passé
qu'est ce que tu aimes faire dans la vie
de la vie de tous les jours qu est ce
que t as me faire et qu'est ce que tu
pourrais faire avec ce que tu aimes
faire pour rendre service et pour aider
tous ces sans abri à qui tu veux donner
toujours la pièce et puis alors qu'il
avait à peine quatre ans eh ben il
arrivé un matin en me disant ben j'aime
bien dessiner
parce que c'est ce que tous les enfants
aiment faire j'aime dessiner
et ben moi en fait je vais je vais
dessiner je vais vendre mes dessins et
avec tout l'argent j'ai acheté deux
maisons sans abri et le but final tu as
tes fans c'est d'acheter un immeuble
maison
j'ai récolté 1527 euros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il vient bolloré c'est vrai que ce qui
fait bon ben c'est quand même ça ne peut
pas laisser indifférent les gens et
c'est quand même avec ses plus de voir
un petit bout de chou réalisé et penser
penser que plein de personnes qui sont
en difficulté est touché par les gens
qui sont dans la rue qui n'ont pas mangé
quand arthur s'arrête pour leur parler
je pense que ça fait du bien aussi aux
gens qui sont par terre d'avoir une
reconnaissance que souvent les gens
passent devant eux avec indifférence
mais lui non voilà il a été sensibilisé
à ça et c'est bien ça s'appelle comment
arsène mais toi c'est une étoile sont
belles c'est toi là tu démontres et
qu'est ce que tu vas faire avec les
étoiles vont enfin tu vas y donnait à
l'époque tu m entends des ports ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arthur on aimerait tant que le monde
soit de ressources
il ya un pouvoir il lui a fallu la
première année quand il a fait quand il
a commencé
il a peut-être gagné 50 euros à toute la
première année la deuxième année ça
c'est multiplier mais en fait c'est
exponentiel donc si cette année il
arriva avec une cagnotte qui s'élève à
1500 euros
qu'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit qu'ils ne
seraient pas à 150 milles pour deux ans
il faut il faut juste y croire en fait
il faut il faut incarner le message
comporte
si nous mêmes on n'est pas convaincu de
ce que je nous fais votre enfant comment
lui peut être convaincu et qu'on en peut
laisser la magie opérer